What's an example of an interactive graphic that you've seen and
that tells a really compelling story?
>> One of my all time favorites is by Amanda Cox, Sean Carter, and
Kevin Quealy of the New York Times.
I'll pull it up over here.
It's actually from 2009,
so you know, it seems like a long time ago, at this point.
But it's an unemployment graphic.
I think people just talk about it as the unemployment graphic.
But it's called The Jobless Rate for People Like You.
Well as, as you can see.
So it's, it's really interesting.
First of all it starts out giving you this line.
So we can see over time from January 2007 to September 2009.
We can see kind of okay the jobless rate has gone up.
Unemployment has gone up.
For all men and women overall.
Right.
But what's really beautiful and
compelling about this is that you can sort of you know,
as soon as you mouse over this piece you know, you can interact with it,
and you can start seeing like these different categories or groupings of people.
And you can use these toggles up here.
So I guess, okay well.
You know, I'm interested in white women in this age group who, you know,
are college graduates.
So we can say, well, for that group, it's like, okay, the,
the employment rate is really pretty low, 3.6%.
But we could change.
Maybe we could say Hispanic men who are younger, for example.
We can see the fluctuations over time for that group, and see that they,
how much higher unemployment rate, at least as of 2009, right.
So I think this is, this is really let's see.
If we click into some of these I think this rescales to, yeah, so You know,
unfortunately, you can see who has the highest unemployment rate.
Like it's so high that we have to rescale the chart, right?
It's a black man, 15 to 24 without a high school degree.
So, and it's really compelling because you can get a sense of the,
kind of massive inequalities here?
But also, you know, the graphic works.
Just on its own.
Like, even if it weren't interactive,
this is the kind of thing you could see published in the paper.
Like a static version, right?
And so you could say,
okay, well, I can see, I can see the unemployment is going up.
But as soon as you have a graphic and you can kind of,
you know, find yourself inside that graphic, I think it makes it really.
Really compelling.
And just by tapping in a couple different categories and say, oh wow,
I'm in this group.
This represents me and now I can see how I compare to the average and
how I can compare to everybody else.